and someone's down  and it looks like it's giannis grabbing  that  right excuse me that left knee  oh no oh my goodness there was a lot of  contact  on the alley there this is something you  absolutely don't want to see  oh you can see the hyperextension you  have the left knee  [Applause]  oh man  [Applause]  can't even look at it no  [Applause]  i mean it is stone the ovation  for one of the great players in the nba  giannis adepakuro  [Applause]  hobbling  they will take him back  [Applause]  to the locker room  never want to see this at all as he's  explaining to his brother  vanessa's  [Applause]  and was just getting kind of warmed up  in this third quarter